Claude Code can now create videos, and
they're actually pretty good. This week,
Remotion dropped a set of skills that
allow Claude Code to create videos just
through prompting. Everything you see
here was generated by these skills, and
you're able to edit individual scenes,
add assets, have Claude go out on the
internet and find assets on your behalf,
and it spawns a video editor in your
local browser. And in today's video, I'm
going to teach you how it works, how to
set it up for yourself, what the best
practices are, and we'll even have a
discussion about whether this tool is
actually going to be taking the jobs of
video editors. So, this prompt to video
functionality is a combination of
Remotion and their agent skills and
Claude code. But it's not just Claude
code. It also works with things like
anti-gravity and open code. Now, how
does this actually work under the hood?
Well, Claude is coding React components
that make up the individual frames that
make up the video. So, imagine a video
that's 30 frames per second and it runs
for 5 seconds, right? 180 frames. Well,
it's coding each individual frame,
putting them all together, and you get
your video. Now, what should get you
really excited isn't that it can just
create videos from a prompt, but that we
can edit these videos through prompting
as well. What you see right here is a
video created by Claude Code. And I told
it, hey, create like a 20 second video
going over the biggest stories in the
NBA so far this season. And it not only
created the video, but it gave us this
entire video editor. So, what do we see?
Well, we are inside of our local host.
It spawned this video editor for us. And
it didn't just give us an MP4 file. It
gave us, you know, all our scenes and
all our frames broken down. It gave us
assets over here on the left. So what we
can do now is we don't have to restart
the video from scratch every time we
want to make an edit. I can just tell it
the individual scene. I can say the
exact frame and say, "Hey, I want to fix
this." So for example, here we are,
scene three, the MVP race. If we zoom in
right here, we can kind of see that the
MVP race and the MVP ladder text boxes
are kind of stacked on one another kind
of weirdly. Well, I can just tell it fix
that and it's going to do it. So, here I
am inside of Cloud Code and I just say,
"Hey, in scene three of the NBA report,
the MVP race slide, the two text boxes
are overlapping. Fix that." And now it's
just going to go ahead and rewrite the
code. And that change will be populated
automatically inside of the editor. And
there's our change basically right away.
Pretty awesome stuff. So, now you're
probably asking, "Cool, how do I
actually do this for myself and how do I
set it up?" Well, luckily, it's actually
really easy. So, let me walk you through
it. So, we will need two things from
Remotion to get started. First, we need
to add the skills. And I'll put this
command down inside the description.
These skills are essentially just a
series of prompts for Claude Code to let
it know how to best use Remotion. This
way, we rely on the skills instead of
relying on some super master secret
prompt to actually get Claude Code to
create good video with Remotion. So,
you're just going to copy this command.
You're going to hop inside your
terminal. You're going to paste it in
there. And then, you're just going to
hit enter. You'll see something like
this pop up. Then it's going to ask you
which agent to install the skills in. So
choose whichever one you're using. And
then from there it will ask you the
scope. I suggest just doing it globally.
Once we have installed the skills, next
thing we need to do is get our project
started. So we're going to do this
command. Again it will be in the
description. You can also find it at
reotion.dev. Head back to your terminal.
At this point you should be inside your
project folder where you actually want
to run this. So paste it in there. Start
it. This is just like starting a React
app. So, it's going to give you a bunch
of options. What I want you to do is go
down to blank. Hit enter. Yes.
Yes. And then it's going to ask you if
you want to open it in VS Code or cursor
and say yes. And you'll see here on the
left, it has installed a bunch of files
for you. So, you're ready to go. Now,
all this stuff like cursor.jemini.open
code, you know, you can delete these if
you don't need them. So, for example, if
you're using cloud code or same goes for
if you're using cursor, if you're using
open code instead. Now, at this point,
you're pretty much ready to go. To get
started, it says to run the npmi and npm
rundev command. Just open up a new
terminal and run those. And that will
get your browser essentially set up with
that video editor. And once you've done
that, now you can actually start Claude
Code.
So, we're going to get Claude Code
started up. And at this point, you can
tell Claude Code, hey, I installed a
bunch of Remotion stuff for you. Go
ahead, check it out, take a look at the
skills, get sort of spun up on what
we're going to do, and I'm going to now
have you create some videos. That's
always like something I like to do. So,
now let's actually use this thing. So, I
have opened up Claude Code. I'm telling
it, I just want to create a 20 second
video using the Remotion skills
highlighting the features of this GitHub
repo, and I pointed towards the GSD
repo. Now, what's the GSD repo? If
you've seen any of my previous videos,
kind of in love with this thing lately.
It's just a framework for Cloud Code for
helping you create apps. But the idea
that we're showing off here is I just
gave it the URL of something and it
should essentially scrape this entire
page. It should also grab assets from
this repo and then it should also figure
out, okay, hey, in 20 seconds, what
would be the best things to highlight
from here, right? And you can kind of
see real quickly the cool applications
we have with this sort of video
generation, right? Throw it a URL. Tell
it to create a video about your web
page. Give it a code base. Tell it to
create an explainer video in 30 seconds
about what your code does and sort of
like the big features, you know, because
it doesn't just create videos. Like we
have the power of cloud code here,
right? It can do a ton of research on
our behalf. It can do a bunch of quote
unquote thinking that you would expect a
human to do if you said, "Hey, do some
research about this video we're going to
create." Right? So, tons of really neat
applications here, especially, you know,
when you combine these two things,
right? It goes beyond just, oh, it
creates videos. So, let's see what it
does. We'll come back. Oh, and one more
thing. I have it on plan mode first.
Highly suggest you do that because we
want to make sure even though we we
don't need to oneshot everything. I want
the first pass to be as good as possible
cuz I know I can edit it down the line
and get real granular, but I want to see
sort of its thinking on the video side
and what it determines is actually
important or not. So, here's the plan.
It came up with five slides for a 20
second video. Hero intro talks about the
context raw problem, agent architecture,
workflow, pipeline, and then a CTA
outro. Okay, on the surface that makes
sense and then proceeds to go a little
bit more in depth of what this is going
to look like now. Okay, typewriter
effect, right? Large. Uh, so it's going
to use that GSD logo, right? So, I'm
assuming it's actually going to pull
that in as an asset. So, lots of cool
stuff here. Um, and this is honestly
just yeah, the existing components. I
think this is sort of the best um
workflow you should use for this where
you kind of just go plan mode first. But
at this point, just let it go forth and
conquer. have it start coding and we'll
see what the final output looks like
after this. And one last little tip, I'm
always super suspect of cloud code using
all the skills it should. So I also ask
at the end before I have it go in code
like did you use all the remote skills
just to make me feel better. Okay, so
it's telling us it finished the video.
So we're just going to head to localhost
3001 in this case and take a look. So we
can see here over on the left it created
GSD video for us and we have our
timeline down here on the bottom. Now
remember this is the first pass. So
let's see how it did at its first
attempt.
So we got the typewriter effect.
Got sort of the motion graphics with the
bar. Got the four things around the GSD.
Kind of got the little gradient in the
background.
Okay. Now was that perfect on the first
pass? No. But that is a solid base to go
from. Right. That took Claude about five
minutes to put that together. If I asked
you to put that together, person who
does not have a motion graphics
background. How long would that take
you? And there's a lot of good things we
can take from this. Now, one thing I was
hoping it would do, which it didn't, was
I kind of wanted it to take that GSD
asset from
the GitHub. So, we can tell it to do
that, or we can just drop the asset in
here on the left ourselves, or I can
just feed into cloud code. So, let's do
that. So, I'm actually just going to
take a screenshot of this. So, I dropped
that screenshot in there and I'm saying,
"Hey, can we use this screenshot of the
GSD logo as an asset? Edit it as
needed." Instead of the GSD text you've
used in this video, right? So, I'm
actually feeding it assets. So, let's
see how that works out. And again, like
you saw also in the um let's bring it up
the NBA video, right? All these assets
of like, you know, the NBA in the
background, you know, SGA,
um Kate Cunningham, like I didn't feed
it any of these. I didn't even do what
we just did in cloud code. I actually
told it, hey, just go out on the web and
find assets that make sense. What I also
did in this particular one, you notice
there's like little cool subtle
animations, right? You can see sort of a
subtle red um behind Cade, the subtle
blue behind SGA. I didn't tell it to do
that. What I actually did at one point
was after it went through its first run,
I was like, "Hey, if you were an expert
motion graphics artist or designer, like
what would you say are some improvements
we can make?" It came up with like 10
improvements, and I just had it add the
ones I felt made sense. So that again,
how long would this take you if you had
none of these skills before? Now this is
just this is just a prompt away. And
kind of going into what we uh alluded to
in the intro of like is this taking
motion graphic jobs? Is this taking
video editor jobs? I I mean this just
came out 2 days ago. This is just like
the first iteration of it. So no, not
yet. But like with anything with AI,
it's just raising the floor
significantly for those of us who don't
show up with these skills. You know,
like I said, I created this what in 20
minutes. Would have taken me 20 hours
otherwise. So, let's see how our asset
thing ended up working out, though. So,
it says it updated it and we can see,
hey, there's our GSD asset. Now, it's
just using the screenshot itself. What
would be nice is if we turned it into a
proper PNG, so we could have like sort
of a transparent background, but you can
see here, right? Actually did a pretty
good job of like adding a border around
it and that sort of thing. You know,
looks looks a lot better here than it
did before. So, but and that took about
one minute for it to do all that. Again,
super cool. Like, you can just continue
to edit and edit and edit. And that for
all intents and purposes is how you use
Remotion inside of Claude Code. Like,
that's the workflow. It's nothing
special. It's actually really easy. Now,
once you're finally good with the video,
it's as easy as just hitting render down
here on the bottom right. And then from
there, you can actually download the
video and post it. So,
yeah, sick tool. So, this is where I'm
going to leave you. As for more
resources, quick plug for the school
down in the comments below. I got the
free school. Again, all the resources
there are free, including tons of Claude
code guides and any templates. The paid
school is more for if you're someone
who's a bit more serious about the stuff
and you're trying to figure out, well,
how can I use these skills to actually
make money? And speaking of that, I'm
also putting on a free webinar this
Saturday, the 31st. You can register for
that in the comments as well. I'm going
to sort of break down my philosophy and
from my experience of how you can
actually make money from the view of an
AI agency because I think there is a lot
of misinformation out there. So, let me
know what you thought about this in the
comments.